Salut ! Aujourd'hui je suis dans les loges du Grand Point Virgule avec François Martinez.
- Salut. C'est moi.
Alors ce mental vlog il est un peu particulier, déjà il est plus court que d'habitude et surtout, je ne fais rien.
Et vous savez pourquoi ? Parce que ce mec là c'est un magicien.
François c'est un pote, à la base on l'appelait Marty, on s'est rencontré, je crois, au PMC 2010.
- Alors ça c'est ce dont il se rappelle.
Moi je l'ai vu beaucoup plus longtemps avant venir faire une conférence, en Bretagne, sur le mentalisme.
C'est vrai ?
-Ouais.
-Ah ouais ?!
-Au cercle ?? de Bretagne.
-Tu m'avais vu euh...
à Lorient...
-Lorient.
-C'était un gros barbu qui m'avait reçu...
-Mais on s'est vraiment rencontrés effectivement en 2010.
Et bah tu vois là j'apprends vraiment un truc. Pour moi c'était dans les loges du PMC...
On s'était rencontrés en loge, bon d'après moi pour la première fois, et surtout il y a eu une galère de présentation de ce spectacle.
-Ouais.
-On a été obligé de co-présenter à l'arrache.
-Ah oui, plus qu'à l'arrache ! On a tout écrit dix minutes avant de monter sur scène.
-Ecrit... Ouais, voilà on se comprend...
Voilà on a eu des trames, et c'était assez rigolo puisqu'à la fin de ce spectacle, tout le monde était persuadé qu'on se connaissait depuis des années.
-Voilà.
-Et du coup c'était vrai.
-D'où la fameuse vanne !
Aujourd'hui il n'est plus du tout en Bretagne et il est pas ailleurs, il est à Paris ! Les dimanches, lundis, mardis pour l'instant au théâtre des Blancs Manteaux.
-Oh ! C'est moi ! En... en photoshop.
-Et ça c'est cool.
Et donc mon kiff à moi c'est qu'aujourd'hui c'est Marty qui va faire un petit tour de magie.
Un alcootest ??
-Ouais. Ça correspond presque à un alcootest tu vois.
-Voilà, c'est mon côté breton. Avec ça tu peux vérifier ton taux d'alcoolémie.
-C'est vrai ?
-C'est à dire voir combien tu as consommé grâce à un simple ballon.
-Alors par contre il faut juste que je trouve ça. Ça, c'est le déclencheur de l'alcootest, c'est génial.
-Et il y a juste à faire ça et apparemment bah je suis presque à  un litre de consommation d'alcool.
-Hein voilà. Et on cachera la marque, comme ça.
Bim !
Truc de dingue !!!
Vous avez vu, je ne vous avais pas menti. C'est vraiment un truc de dingue. Il fait des trucs de dingue sur scène.
Allez voir son spectacle, c'est les dimanches, lundis et mardis au théâtre des Blancs Manteaux à Paris et si ça se trouve au moment où tu regarderas cette vidéo, il y aura d'autres dates...
Donc le plus simple, c'est que tu suives le descriptif que je mets dans le lien.
Merci beaucoup mon Marty !
-De rien ! C'est moi qui te remercie !
-Bravo à toi.
Et quant à nous rendez-vous demain à 17h pour le prochain mental vlog. Ciao !